color matching all your Sony cameras
Sony keeps improving their color signs
and when using film simulations each
model will have a slight color
difference so let's see how to adjust
these film recipes to match for this
comparison I have the Sony RX100 Mark 6
the a73 and the a6700 and I've used the
coch Chrome film solation recipe with
all cameras this is how they come up
with the same settings and the
differences are clear to the eye but
easily match with a couple simple
adjustments the main problem is the
RX100 is colder and on the C side with
the colors while the a73 is heavily
magenta casted and the a6700 being well
balanced in the middle to mash these on
the RX100 add the temperature by 300
shifted the color pH to minus 4 and
these adjustments added more warmth to
the image and shifted the Blu towards
magenta and skin toes towards Amber the
Sony a73 is cold and on the magenta side
so to fix this issue I lifted the color
phase to plus one to correct the
magentas raised the temperature by 100
Kelvin and set the color filter from A7
m75 to straight A7 the final results
come much closer to each other and this
is all straight out of camera you can
check out my blog for more